what's that believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in
people more than they believe in
themselves I my sincere hope is that if
you see in you what I see in you you'll
be able to change the planet so to help
you on your journey today I'm going to
talk about the seven ways to convince
people to buy your product so one of the
most common challenges for entrepreneurs
is we've got a great product or service
to sell and we got to get out there and
sell it how do you convince people that
they need to buy your thing I'm gonna
give you my seven tips tip number one is
to change your mindset I'm not from the
old school sales philosophy where you
see that next person coming in as your
next suit or as your next car or hitting
your next bonus from my perspective
what's really important is you're trying
to serve them you're trying to actually
help this person make a good decision
that may mean pushing them a little bit
that may mean once you understand them
to give them the best solution and we'll
go through the points but it starts with
the mindset of you are there to serve
you are there to help and not just try
to close I'm not trying to convince
anybody of anything I want to help the
person coming through the door and if
you start with that approach I think
every other step becomes a lot easier
the reason why it's so important is
because you can spend so much of your
time dealing with people who are not
good fits for your business a lot of
people a lot of you guys if you have a
list of potential leads or prospects a
lot of these people will never buy from
you and you either spend your time
trying to convince the people who are
not fits for your company to buy from
you and it's a long slow painful awkward
process for both of you or you abandon
that person and you use that time to
focus on finding people who are good
fits for your business and so spend less
time trying to convince everybody and
more time finding and helping the people
who you can help
[Music]
step number two is to listen to them the
best tool that you have as a salesperson
is your ears there's a common singing of
there's a reason why you have two ears
and one mouth you need to be able to
listen to your customers to understand
what they're looking for the worst
salesperson and you can even experience
it whatever you're going to go out and
buy at the if your deal with the
salesperson is they're just talking at
you talk and talk and talk and talk and
talking you're probably gonna get one
really annoyed and - a lot of what
they're saying is not going to help you
and so if you want to switch that if you
want to be a great salesperson your
first step is to listen to what the
people are saying listen to what their
problems are listen to try to find
points that you understand their
challenge and then it's easy to come up
with solution that will help them also
as people are talking it helps them to
feel a little bit more understood which
improves your sales process cycle as
well tip number three is understand
their why this is always a really
important process and one where a lot of
sales people fall down because people
come in with one reason for why they
think they're buying from you or why
they think they're interested but
there's always a deeper reason which
they may acknowledge or they may need a
couple probing questions to figure out
so as an example people come to dents
here right stronger than salsa or the
largest day in school for salsa in
Canada for sure maybe North America why
do people come here when you ask them at
the beginning is well I want to learn
some steps I want to you know on a I
thought salsa was interesting I want to
I want to come and learn and it's a very
surface level answer it doesn't give me
anything if I'm trying to sell this
person if I'm trying to help this person
make a decision as to which class might
be a right fit or even if our school is
a good fit for them or not I need to
understand why they're coming here right
so as an example if what they all they
care about is the steps and and their
goal is to perform and they want to be
one of the world's greatest salsa
dancers I'm not gonna sell them on a
group class because you learn more
slowly maybe they want to do private
lessons with an instructor to learn as
quickly as possible most people though
what they do is they come and they want
to meet people maybe they just broke up
with somebody and they want to get into
a new relationship maybe they just move
to the city and they want to make new
friends maybe they're not happy with
their work and they just need an escape
to go
- maybe they haven't made any friends
since University the people of the work
they don't really like or they're an
entrepreneur and they work by themselves
and they want to come and meet people
right if that's the incentive to want to
join that's good Neil because when I'm
done talking to them I can frame
everything in a situation that really
helps them best and so you have to
understand the why behind the why
usually it's not the first answer but
it's the second or the third answer so
when you ask them why did you find us
what inspired you to call what inspired
you to come into my store what inspired
you to you know send me that email ask
one-level why at least deeper after you
get that first response because almost
by default and this is when you're doing
with a team member this is when you're
dealing with investors when you do with
media you know there's always a wide
behind the why so ask the why and then
when they give you a response ask a
second why or third why underneath to
get to the real core because you
understand what really moves them you
understand the true intention behind it
and probing them a little bit to figure
that out you have a much better chance
of giving them the best option and
closing that sale tip number four is
make a connection at the beginning of
this process is always this kind of
standoff right nobody likes to be sold
nobody likes being sold to people like
the five but they don't like being sold
to and so whenever a salesperson comes
up to somebody immediately like you
tighten up you holding your breath you
don't want to reveal too much you don't
want to be hard pressure sold that's a
typical reaction that happens a lot but
they do want information they do want
somebody to help them and so by figuring
out their why right the why behind the
why the next step that you want to do is
make a personal connection with them
somehow show them that you understand
their why so if you if they're talking
about wanting to come take a dance class
because they want to make new friends
because they haven't made any friends
since college right or if they are
trying to get into relationship they're
hoping to meet somebody because I just
broke up with somebody try to hear a
personal story that relates to them so
sharing a good personal story one shows
that you listen to them one shows that
you are understanding them and then also
shows that you have a solution for them
because you've gone through it yourself
because you know what situation they're
in you've come through it and now I'm
going to show you
path to do it yourself and so if someone
was talking like that as an example I
would share about all the great
friendships that I've made through
dancing how my social circle exploded
because I took dance classes became part
of the social security that's one of the
most friendly communities I think in the
world I did barroom dancing didn't meet
anybody it took zossen my friend Circle
exploded I then met my wife if you're
talking relationships I met my wife
through a salsa dancing it's a great way
to be able to meet people because you're
in a dance class and you're rotating
partners every couple minutes so you get
to know all the members of the opposite
sex in your class and when you go out
the socials and parties part of the
process is you're dancing with lots of
different people you don't just stick
with one partner out all night you're
dancing with twenty thirty forty
different people from the opposite sex
in one night and so friendships just
naturally happen relationships just
naturally happen and I can share my
story and so if I understand that that's
your real why behind the why and then I
share with you my personal story not as
a sales pitch to try to convince you but
a deep understanding of I am I knowledge
this fear that you have and this pain
that you have in this desire you have
and then here's how I solved it then
it's much easier to get them to follow
that path with you you disarm them they
feel like they're not being sold anymore
but you're actually trying to help tip
number five is recommend a solution that
fits and so once you've asked the why
behind the why and once you've made that
connection with them then you have to
think okay I now really know what this
person wants and I know why they want it
now I need to figure out what's the best
option for me to be able to give that
person you know what China Dennis also
we have lots of different classes we
have lots of different options we have
salsa we have bachata we have
performance groups we have private
lessons we have lots of different things
that you could potentially do and as I'm
talking to somebody you know we'll be
listening okay here's what they need
here's what they're asking for that's an
X that's a yes and in some cases and
this is this is bold but this earns a
lot of trust it may mean that you
recommend them outside of your company
maybe the best thing for them to do is
not be a part of your company so example
when people call in to us to say hey do
you have a kids program well we don't
write
there is no kids program is something
that we've thought about we're looking
into but it's not a highest priority
right now for us and so instead of just
saying no it could also be okay here are
some options you know if you get the
question enough you can look at
different options here are some other
schools that provide kids programs so
maybe I'm sending my potential customer
you know to one of my competitors but
it's the best thing for them and they'll
remember it it's not often that that
happens that I cuss a company is willing
to recommend you to their competition
and whether you want to take that bold
step or not I can guarantee you that it
net net wins for you because they
remember that relationship and if they
have another potential option or
question they're going to come back to
you but even if you don't recommend off
to a competing product just be able to
recommend the right thing for them not
just the thing that you're trying to
sell more of so a great example a buddy
of mine named Louis runs a company
called last minute training they sell
all sorts of different training so
example if you want to learn Excel you
know he'll put you into different Excel
classes he knows which Excel classes
best fit for the customer but he also
knows the ones that are gonna make him
the most money he will always do the
best thing for the customer even if he's
gonna make more money off of this course
and send him on this day but he knows it
doesn't quite fit their criteria he
doesn't doesn't quite give them what
they want he focuses on the customer
experience first and that in turn wins
loyalty I mean it's a it's a great way
of doing business at arms
you know team respect and team loyalty
so it's not just about the money but it
also keeps the client if they know that
you gave them the best option for them
even if you're losing a little bit of
money because of it it earns their trust
earns our loyalty it earns their
referrals and it's a great way to do
business
[Music]
good number sixes go above and beyond
you need to get referrals for your
business unless you have money to go and
buy Super Bowl commercials and spend a
ton of money and ads entrepreneurs often
build their business through referrals
you do a fantastic job for somebody and
then they hopefully come back for repeat
business but it also may be the business
where they may not want to buy from you
for another two or three years or five
years depending on the industry but you
want them to refer people on to you you
want people to pass your name on to them
because of the great experience that you
gave them and unfortunately providing a
good product or service isn't enough
like you could give them everything that
they wanted everything that they asked
for but is that's just the bare minimum
because remember your customers are busy
people think about how busy you are
think about all the things that you have
bought in the past year how many of
those things have you referred on to
your friends like how many of those do
go out of your way sure if somebody asks
you hey do you have a real estate agent
you can refer me to maybe you pass on
the name but that you go out of your way
to say man I had this crazy experience
with this real estate agent this guy is
so amazing I need to tell you about that
right how many times have you done that
probably not that much most companies
operate at a pretty you know high level
of mediocrity and most companies don't
even get to the point where you're you
know really satisfied but that's the
bare minimum to entry just solving some
of these problem is not enough you have
to think about how you can go above and
beyond to make it a special not just
product or service but experience for
them so every time they are involved
with your company in any way a phone
call in person email social media
however they're interacting with you
they feel great as a result on top of
getting the product service benefits
that you promised on top of solving
their problem and so be looking at
through the entire process of dealing
with a customer how can you make the
experience better more enjoyable more
memorable more pleasant so they can't
help but go and tell their friends about
this amazing time that they just had
with this insane customer service story
the URL to provide for them one of the
things that we always do at TDS as part
of our process is the last step so we've
the checklist of things that we want to
do for
customers when they call in the last
step is always look for a way to go
above and beyond part of that is
understanding the why like to give them
something that is really above and
beyond you have to understand what their
why was you have to understand why
they're getting into it so an example
somebody new to the city wants to make
new friends once they get to know the
city feels like dance class is a great
way to do it perfect let's look at
solving the problems let's look and get
into them too into a class and be the
best fit for them salsa bachata whatever
it is great we found the class perfect
signed up happy pleasant experience on
the phone it's not enough we have to go
above and beyond thinking about here's a
person who's new to the city what can we
do that will really help them well is it
thinking about other events that happen
in the city is it is it understanding
what neighborhood they're part of and
different festivals that you really like
going to is it recommending restaurants
that you've had a great experience at
that they absolutely should go and try
because you know they told you on the
phone something about their personal
preference like you gotta find something
that really tags you to them not just
because it's a strategy it's just it's a
good thing to do like you'll feel more
fulfilled that you're really deeply
meaningfully helping these customers and
they'll feel a lot more honesty and
trust and loyalty towards you that
they'll not only want to come back and
look forward to that first experience
come back for future experiences but
also tell their friends you need the
word of mouth and that comes from
providing an extraordinary experience on
top of the product or service that
you're selling tip number seven is model
success remember any problem that you
have right now somebody's already solved
it there's a lot of great people who've
done a lot of great different sales
training that you can pick from it
doesn't mean you have to follow
anybody's methodology exactly to the to
the tea I've given you seven tips here
today
you mean like two of them great apply
that your business see if it works and
see if it doesn't it's never been easier
to reach out to experts if you're at a
company you know maybe there's somebody
above you who can reach out to but also
just in general experts people putting
on live YouTube hangouts people who are
on Twitter people who are on snapchat
you can make a video and reach out to
somebody who knows what they're talking
about and get direct feedback for your
business it's never been easier to do it
and whether you're doing that whether
you're watching videos whether you're
reading books constantly educate
yourself remember that that big problem
that you're facing you
we'll have to come up with every single
ingenious idea your self somebody has
already figured it out
learn from them take what works for you
apply it to your business and take off
so those are my seven tips on ways to
convince somebody to buy your product
I'd love to know what do you guys think
what was your favorite tip what are you
going to apply immediately into your
process share it down below
did I miss an eight nine ten that you
want to add to the list leave it down in
the comments if you leave a comment
within a couple hours of this video
going live you are entered into our
contest for two Deeley prizes I made
this video because Syed Abbas asked me
to so if there's a topic you'd like me
to cover in a future seven ways video
check out the link in the description
click on that go leave your topic go
vote on the other ones that are there
and you might get lucky and I'll cover
it next time I also want to give a quick
shout out to Regina Ross Thomas Regina
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word and taking that
picture and sending it to me I love the
smile I love the background I hope
you're enjoying the read and I really
really appreciate the support thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love Elsie's